do you remember the first time you heard
the term crowdfunding or you learned
what Kickstarter or IndieGoGo is and
what was your first impression of
crowdfunding and now what is it well our
friend Jocelyn town who made I am I
which is a wonderful film and they were
one of the first films to make over a
hundred thousand dollars on Kickstarter
and so she was talking to us about the
process and we were in her video so that
really introduced us to the idea it's
the first time I'd really remove it ya
think it's a great video I love it yeah
yeah here we were the parents okay okay
parents not parents did I see parents no
but someone could I sapir right that
would be there say yeah I'm confusing
yeah um yeah so that's when we first
heard of it and it's really a great you
know sort of form of patronage and a way
for people to give to the arts and it's
kind of an exciting time mm-hmm and do
you think it'll still be around in 10
years it's a great question more meth I
don't know i don't think about it
reaching a saturation point where you
know and you know everyone has a
Kickstarter and therefore no one is you
know no one cares no one can i've been
looking at a lot of the crowdfunding
hashtag on twitter and there seems to be
a lot of um I know icky entrepreneurial
content sort of like I don't know a lot
of workshops and things like that are
wonderful but there's also that sort of
know what am I trying to say please fax
please factory yeah and I feel like
people are becoming aware of it which is
great because people who need it can
find it but there is also that sleaze
factor sort of there and I think you
know if there are large amounts of
people who get burned on on some sort of
crowdfunding thing where they give money
and then the makers don't end up not
knowing what they're doing
end up not fulfilling their incentives
or you know whatever it is I think if
people start getting burned that in my
targeting us have a sort of the
stigmatized sort of association with it
hopefully that won't happen hopefully it
will just continue to grow and and will
stick around because it's really sort of
a great way of leveling up the playing
field for artists and it's great way of
taking out the gatekeepers I mean if you
look at what was it not that the video
game one that that just did millions in
our children mmm something well the
everyone else probably knows better than
me but that the big companies wouldn't
fund that sort of video game and then
everyone on Kickstarter came in and gave
them a bajillion dollars and got the
thing that they wanted that the money
people thought they didn't want so it
can also go the other way of becoming
more like that where it's less sort of
people working out of their apartment
it's sort of big you know not the
corporations but the companies we all
have been real companies sort of you
know getting the the limelight and
smaller artists never looking to find an
audience I think there's room for
everyone that because those big
companies help people go to the venue
and then they play around and find other
things I know that's what I do if a
friend of mine has a Kickstarter I'll go
look at it and then two hours later I
fact three projects because I looked at
other things I was there too so right
time will tell yeah right i think i was
reading on was it gawker com that
sometimes they liken it to being at a
party in someone trying to sell you an
way because having been on both sides of
it having had our own Kickstarter
campaign you want to be able to tell
people but at the same time there's sort
of a fine line what's the way to do it
in a very what's way to finesse it how
do you let people know without being too
Oh fund me you know well I haven't
knowing myself with our current
Kickstarter campaign so
the idea instance is to look at it as
sort of a way of testing out the
marketplace with your idea to see if if
it's something that people want which I
went to lactose pre-selling your idea
and you don't have the funds to make it
but here here's this product do you want
it and if it's something that people
want then it'll be it'll be easier to
try to sell people on it the kickstart
is where people end up sort of begging
for money even though we feel that we're
begging for money sometimes is are those
ones where they they don't really have
very good incentives like you know we're
making a book if you give two hundred
dollars you get a copy the book it's a
well you know celebrating for how much
it's I went so the book is out i can buy
it for 25 bucks yeah so we look at it
and actually trying to make it so
they're getting more for their money
than if they'd waited for when it comes
out so um you know for twenty-five
dollars for our current one they get
they get the copy the movie they get a
digital copy the movie they get a you
know kickstarter exclusive audio
commentary and you know invitation to
after parties and stuff so trying to
make it something something that people
will want as opposed to hey please give
me a lot of money so that I can have
money to my thing I think there's an
element of people liking the idea of
helping mm-hmm which is attractive but
also they need to get something for the
money that makes it seem equitable and
worthwhile well after them and you also
have something where if they're within
two hours of LA like a comedy good
comment yeah yes yes fine okay we one of
the things that we started doing when we
first came to LA was before the
two-person comedy duo that's sort of in
the vein of bone nicholson man your
seller and Mira or Burns and Allen
except hopefully he won't work me to
death so right I'm more familiar with
classic waiting Island get that but uh
yeah so we we did that we created this
act and we
around doing and stuff and the idea was
oh we'll do our hacked and you know
maybe we'll get representation and then
we'll start getting auditions and then
maybe we'll start producing our stuff
and then we just thought well let's just
skip them to the skip the middleman and
start producing the things that we want
to produce but we still have racked you
still love performing live and people
wants to come forward their venue will
will come to it you have a band I think
there's some in san cisco exam that is
in the movie of the directors husband
band the chief enablers um actually
shooting it Oh daddy yes hey I was
corrected on that no chief named Keith
nale is uh they will go i think it's it
within 50 miles or two hours of the bay
area ok and they'll play a gig salinas
yeah absolutely
you